but you know the mainstream media is
canceling us and just recently because
uh we are growing in the pool that they
are speaking about us but that growth
was ordinary canadian using their social
media speaking to their families their
friends about the bbc because our
biggest challenge right now is still a
lot of people don't know that we exist
don't know that there's another option
and we didn't have that conversation
during that electoral campaign all the
other political parties agree with
vaccine passports and lockdowns and we
are the only one but we were not part of
that national uh debate in the
mainstream media and yes you're right
after this election we'll have a couple
of candidates that will be elected and i
i believe that i'll be able to be
re-elected in my riding in bose and
we'll have that conversation and the
mainstream media won't be able to ignore
us anymore
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to have with
me today
one of the contenders for the prime
ministership of canada the honorable
maxine bernier the leader of a new
canadian political party the people's
party of canada he was minister of
industry minister of foreign affairs and
minister of state for small business and
tourism in stephen harper's conservative
government and he was an mp for the
writing of bose for 13 years and is
currently running for election there
in 1985 mr bernier earned a bachelor of
commerce degree from the university of
quebec montreal
and entered law at the university of
ottawa he was called to the quebec bar
in 1990 he worked for a variety of
financial and banking institutions
before becoming executive vice president
of the montreal economic institute in
2005.
he ran for leadership of the progressive
conservative party in 2017. that's
generally canada's dominant or second
place party
finishing second to andrew scheer who
the current pc leader progressive
conservative leader aaron o'toole
replaced
maxime founded the ppc in 2018
citing disagreements with shir's
leadership
mr bernie and i came into personal
contact during the controversy
surrounding canada's bill c-16 which
purported to protect the rights of trans
individuals but was regarded by me and
others as a
as a threat to
free speech um i invited aaron o'toole
the current pc leader to this podcast uh
he had other commitments and declined
and i invited mr bernier and he agreed
to talk so we get to meet again and so
it's really good to see you and
thanks very much for agreeing to talk
thank you mr peterson jordan i'm very
pleased to be with you and you're right
by saying that the first time we were in
contact it's when i called you
in 2017 because now i know that i did a
mistake at that time i voted for that
bill c-16
and i didn't know a lot about that that
was the party position of the
conservative party of canada at that
time
and
i voted in line with the party line but
after that some of my friends told me
maxima i believe that you did a mistake
that deal it's not only about gender
identification it's about free speech
and you must have a discussion with mr
peterson and we had a phone conversation
at that time and you uh you explained me
the impact of that deal and i was
admitted that you are right uh and i was
wrong at that time but i was a little
bit
naive about all that
transgender and cultural next marxism
and
all that walk culture
because jordan when i decided to be in
politics i just as you just said in my
bio i was more a kind of an economist i
work only three years as a lawyer in a
big law firm in montreal
but after that
i worked in a financial institution and
i was working
for the montreal economic institute
that's a think tank a free market think
tanks in montreal
and i was vp over there so when i
decided to be in politics i decided to
be in politics for a smaller government
more freedom less government
intervention
and more free markets uh you know i was
that's why i decided to go in politics
and all that
uh
cultural marxism and now that world
culture i didn't know anything about
that
and what i liked when i was a minister
was to
do a deregulation in the telecom
industry um and professor schultz at
university mcgill said that i was the
best minister of industry
for the last 30 years because of that
deregulation so more competition prices
went down for the telecom and cell phone
uh but uh all that was not part also of
my platform for the leadership of the
conservative party of canada in 2017. my
platform was very more a kind of a
conservative libertarian less government
believing in people not in big fat
government and i had something about
extreme multiculturalism at that time
and also
on immigration
but uh you i was in in contact with
all that wall culture and bill c-16
after a discussion that we had and now
today today it's part of my campaign
it's part of the of the
people's party of canada
and i'm speaking about it every day
because it's a reality
it's a sad reality of our country right
now
yeah well a lot of that sort of
legislation
is
a wolf in sheep's clothing because it
purports to be kind and compassionate
and to
be solely for the benefit of people who
are oppressed in some unfair manner
but there are uh sharks and crocodiles
lurking beneath the surface and
um it's it's not necessarily that easy
to see them and i think that's really
been hard on center
thinkers and and people who are more on
the right as well because they get
defeated often before they even have a
chance to speak because the woke crowd
is extraordinarily good at setting the
stage for the political discussion we
saw a lot of that in the debate for
example in the last leaders debate
you upset to write on that and
that's why
now
we are the only national political party
that has a policy on gender identity
can you believe that um for me uh you
know
back five years ago for me that was not
an issue but now it's an issue and we
are speaking about that when you have
legislation or here in canada when you
have men
that are saying that they're a woman
with and going to a prison for for for
women in the same prison uh you you have
you have that in canada and when you
have men that are in a competition
against women in sport
and that's supposed to be normal
so so that's why we needed to have a
policy on that in our platform and
that's a policy that is very popular
because we go back to the common sense
and i think there's a lack of common
sense in our country right now the
common sense is not that common these
days but
i'm speaking about it openly and more
and more people can understand
that we want to
live in a free society when you don't
have any racial politics or identity
politics or gender issues like that
so
you've you founded the people's
party of canada in 2018 that's is that
correct and and that was dissatisfaction
in part with the leadership of andrew
scheer and with the conservative
platform in general and so
it's a radical move just to start a new
political party and of course people
have pointed out and i'm sure you were
aware of this regardless that one of the
risks of doing that is that you split
the vote and that as a consequence you
move the probability of power more into
the hands of people whose policies you
might not agree with and so why do you
why did you think that it was worth why
did you think it was necessary worth the
risk and necessary and do you feel this
is a few years later that that you were
justified in that assumption
yes i i believe that it was
the the best political decision
in my political career i'm very pleased
that we did it but yes at that time when
i was a conservative and that was just
after the leadership contest in 2017 i
didn't win with 49 of the vote and i try
and we we had a very popular platform
very popular conservatives free market
smaller government
and
and after a couple of months i believe
maybe 12 months
i was trying at that time to
have the leadership of the conservative
party of canada
to to take some of our ideas that were
very popular with the membership of the
conservative party of canada
and
andrew scheer said publicly
that
you know
when i'm speaking about policies i'm
speaking only for myself i not engage
the party and the platform for the next
election the 2019 after that will be a
platform very different than the
platform that i ran on for the for the
con for the leadership of the
conservative party of canada so i said
why staying with the political party and
running at the election of 2019 with a
party when you don't believe in that
platform and for me that party was not
conservative centrist and a little bit
centered to the left and i said when i
resigned this party the conservative
party of canada is intellectually and
morally corrupt and that's why i created
the people's party of canada based on
four principles
individual freedom personal
responsibility respect and fairness and
and all our policies are in line with
these principles and we don't do
politics by survey or polling we believe
that we have the right vision for this
country and we are speaking about what
we believe openly with passion and
conviction and i believe that i will be
able to have more support
but in the election like you just said
jordan the 2019 election that was the
first election for the people's party of
canada and i didn't win by seating vote
i was running as the leader and people's
party candidate we had 1.6 of the vote
300 000 people voted for us
but for our first year we did better
than the green party of canada because
it took the green party of canada
uh 20 20
elects 20 years and six elections to
have more than 1.6 of the vote and we
did that in our first year but the
biggest argument coming from the
conservatives again against us was the
fact that oh don't vote for bernie
you'll you'll divide the vote you're
going to split the vote and and i can
tell you that was very efficient i saw
people out west and all across the
country maxime we like your ideas we
like your platform but our most
important uh
goal is to get rid of justin trudeau we
don't want to split the vote so we won't
support you that argument was very
efficient but now we know that you know
they voted for
some conservatives voted for the
conservative party and in russia and
they end up with justin trudeau and now
you have the same argument in 2021 but
it is less effective because aaron
utulno is more leftist
than andrew scheer and the party if you
look at the platform of the liberal
party of canada and the conservative
they're the same on imposing a vaccine
passport work culture
not balancing the budget i can go on and
go on so people realize now a little bit
more then you know if you vote for
bernie it is not a vote for the liberals
it is a vote for yourself for your
values and and if aaron utol is winning
he will be like justin trudeau on the
most important issues for the future of
our country so that argument is less
effective and i believe that's why also
we are growing in the polls right now as
you know the election will be this
monday and uh i'm speaking about our
freedom and speaking about
the fact that we have draconian measures
that are that these government not only
the federal one but the provincial one
provincial ones are imposing on us and
and that freedom of speech freedom of
expression freedom of choice is very
important in this campaign and we are
able to grow our support i don't know
what will be
the result at the end of this campaign
but i can feel a kind of a momentum and
we'll see what will happen where where
do you think you are in the polls right
now what what do you think's a reliable
figure
yeah so we don't do any internal polling
we don't do that we don't believe in
that i'm looking at the public polls and
we are between
seven percent nationally to 11 12
nationally in some provinces like in
ontario we are around 8
in alberta around 10
so i believe that
we can have
maybe a strong
six or seven percent of the vote and if
we have that from 1.6 to six or seven
percent that would be a big victory if
we have that score we will have more
votes than the green party of canada
because since the beginning of that
campaign the green party is around three
and four percent and us we started that
campaign at 1.6 like now we are around 6
7 and maybe 12 so we'll be able to do
better than the green and maybe do
better than the block quebecois that is
a regional political party only in
quebec they're at six percent in the
polls so
we
the mainstream media and the political
elites will have to speak about us and
engage with us about our ideas so that
will be the beginning uh for us of a new
step and another step for for the growth
of our party because this party is there
for a long term
and we won't merge with any party we
will always fight for what we believe
and pushing our ideas because like i
said we are doing politics differently
and it's not a slogan it's a reality
usually when you're a politician
you will speak about a subject when
maybe 38 35 of the population is on that
side because your goal is to have a
majority
and you'll start to speak about it and
hope that you have 50 percent on one
subject for us that's not important we
are doing politics based on ideas and we
believe that we have the best ideas like
i said i'll give you an example you know
speaking about ending the uh
the
the supply management system in canada
that's a cartel for poultry dairy and
milk
these producers are fixing the price in
canada cannot export and that's why
canadians are paying twice the price for
milk full tree and eggs in our country
we want to abolish that and being sure
that we will be it will be a free
free market for these products
but when i'm speaking about that you
know
the huge majority 70 percent of the
population agree with that system so
what we need to do we need to speak
about it more often and more people will
be on our side and that's the way we are
doing politics we don't
okay so let me ask you let me ask you
about that so well okay i want to
summarize some of the things you said
see if i've got this right so your
feeling is that
uh
that
the conservatives in some sense because
they're
doing politics by pull
are drifting into the center and the
center left and and yes and you are
providing an alternative set of ideas
and you think that the provision of that
set of ideas is important enough to
canadians broadly speaking that taking
the risk of dividing the vote is a good
short and long term measure
these ideas need to be brought into the
public forum and it's it's risky there's
great risk in not doing it and and you
also think that your party
and so then why why is it as well that
your party has decided that you're going
to stick to your
your philosophical platform let's say
rather than being led by polls and and
do you really think you can avoid doing
that in in the long run
our goal is not to be in power that's
not the end goal yes i hope everybody
will be elected but our end goal is to
speak about our ideas and when they will
become popular and we know that you know
an idea
an idea will become popular if you speak
about it so the more we speak about it
the more support we'll have and the more
candidates will be elected so the
conservative they're they are only
conservative in name right now and what
are new tool is doing by
speaking like the leftists and and
and and and using that narrative is not
helping the real conservative cause and
auto is not speaking about that because
it is not popular today we are in a
socialist era in canada and in other
countries so if your main goal is to be
in government
you you will you know there's about 70
60 percent of the populations in canada
that are leftist so that's why the
conservative is going to the left
because the only goal is to be in
government our goal is not to be in
government i hope a day i'll be prime
minister but i'm realistic our goal is
to have increase our percentage of the
vote to have some candidates that will
be elected this election and growing our
support and up the next election will be
more powerful will be
more candidates and that's why our
electoral campaign for this election our
electoral platform for this election is
the same one than the last election in
2019 and it would be the same one in
2022 or at the next election because
you know why do you why do you think
these ideas are so important that
so so canadians are going to often vote
to throw someone out rather than to
bring someone in let's say and maybe
often that's how democracies function
and it's hard to say whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing um that that
isn't what you're doing precisely you're
trying to bring these ideas into a wider
public forum
why do you think that's so important and
why do you think that you have the
background knowledge to make that
decision like right because you formed a
party you're you're tr you're changing
the political landscape in canada you're
taking a big personal risk as well this
isn't an easy thing to do so what is it
that you're doing that you're offering
that's so vital and important that all
of that is worthwhile and and and why
should canadians take that risk
what happens if they if you don't do
this
that will happen
we'll be in that leftist era for longer
than we thought uh you know we have more
and more draconian news measures right
now
i'm speaking about covington 19 uh you
know in in alberta they will have uh
a vaccine passport in quebec we have a
vaccine passport in ontario we have a
vaccine passport don't get me wrong i'm
not again that vaccine
you know everybody must be free to
choose if they want the vaccine or not
with the right information but right now
we are imposing a vaccine passport so we
are dividing the society in society into
two groups you know the vaccinated
people and the unvaccinated people and
some of them
will have more rights than other that
that's not what we want in a free
society everybody must be equal before
the law and we know that everybody can
spread the virus the vaccinated people
and the unvaccinated people we know that
if you took the vaccine you'll have mild
symptoms if you have coven-19 and your
chances of
spreading the virus is a little bit
minimum but everybody can spread the
virus look at what is happening right
now in israel
and
there's a lot of people there that took
the vaccine
and they can spread the virus so why i
won't be able to go to a restaurant
because i decided personally enough to
take the vaccine i'm 58 years old and if
i'm looking at the data and the
statistic coming from our country from
statistic canada i have 0.5 percent
chances of dying if i have coven covid
so my my survival rate is 99.5
so i decided not to take the vaccine but
my dad is 87 years old diabetic and i
encourage him to take the vaccine and
the two shots and he did it so we just
want people to be free and now i'm not
able to go to a restaurant or to a
baseball game because i didn't take the
vaccine and everybody can spread it and
i know that if i'm at a restaurant and
the table just near me there's people
who took the vaccine they're protected
and they're not more in danger because
i'm there so we must be fair for
everybody and stop that kobe dysteria we
need to learn to live with that virus he
will be there we cannot have zero kovind
19 in one country it won't happen we
need to learn to live with it if not we
will live with more iniquity and and
justice and i don't want that so so
that's why you know
so let me play let let me play devil's
advocate for a minute i'll take
our prime minister stated a couple of
weeks ago i believe that
pretty much had no sympathy for anyone
who was unvaccinated who ended up in the
hospital for example and you might say
well the vaccines are widely available
and so and people can get them whenever
they want and so why in the world
shouldn't they do it the science
supports their utility these aren't my
claims by the way
the sign supports their utility and if
they're too damn stupid to get the
vaccine then why then they're limiting
their own freedoms and everyone else's
security is paramount okay so what's
wrong with that argument in your view
but it is wrong
at that basis because first of all yes
we are free to decide but what that
argument what that argument is saying is
if you want to be free you need to have
the vaccine passport and that would
create two kinds of citizens like i said
in the beginning and that will create or
show me your paper society that
vaccinated people will have to show
their papers to participate in the
society and maybe unvaccinated people
will have to show maybe a negative covet
test to participate in the society we
don't want that because
because kavit is there there's no
difference between me that i didn't take
the vaccine another person if you if you
decide if you decided to take the
vaccine to protect yourself not the
society now we have the the
immunity that is there out there and yes
there are some variants but
the most important is we
we must learn to live with that virus
we're not must care
people and now what justin trudeau is
saying if you work for the federal
government and you don't have your two
shots you don't have the vaccine you
don't have the vaccine passport he said
you know there will be consequences that
his words there would be consequences so
he wants to punish people that decided
not to take the vaccine you know
everybody that's unconstitutional that's
illegal
you know
your personal health choice must be
private if your employer is asking you
do you did you take the vaccine or not
canadians
must not answer that question it's your
personal private health information and
you must have that discussion with your
doctor now the and you know all our
personal information would be up there
with that code qr that we have in quebec
and vaccine passport they're gonna know
your your your status your your age uh
what what you're doing which institution
you you are going it is a little bit
like a social credit in china
maybe i'm exaggerated yes but it's going
to that direction and i don't like that
you know i see in some countries i think
it's australia where there's technology
where now you have to take a snapshot of
yourself in a particular locale at a
particular time and that the phone can
tell the people the authorities that
you're reporting to if you're actually
there and
you know for for people who are
concerned with governmental overreach
the establishment of such technologies
regardless of the rationale poses a
substantial existential danger that's
that's comparable in some sense to the
health danger presented by the well by
the pandemic and
so
that that that seems to be what you're
suggesting i would say and so all right
so let's let's talk about if
what do you think canada should look
like in three months then in
relationship to covid so so you envision
a completely open country fundamentally
uh what is what what do you think we
should do
but i think we should do like in other
countries or another state that didn't
uh lock down their economy lock down
people and
and shut down their economy and thinking
about florida with governor descenses
texas
and other countries
what we did with kovite 19 just the fact
that the true government with the
354 billion dollars that the trudeau
government span because of kovind 19
that was the biggest deficit in our
history and what he said he said you
know
he said to provinces you can lock down
your province i will i will finance your
economic loss i will give grants and
subsidies to businesses for them to stay
close and i will create a program for
canadians that was not the solution it's
a medical expert and the expert that
signed the bollington declaration in the
u.s said that you know we must we must
yes lock down the most vulnerable
canadians and that canadians older
canadians with co-morbidities and open
the economy that was a big mistake and
now and now we are paying for that with
our huge deficit we are paying for that
because there's a lot of waiting lists
for surgeries right now and we
we lock down the economy
suicide rates it's going up depression
uh that was not the solution and i hope
that
right now or just after the election all
these lockdowns and mass mandate that
are imposing on people must end and
that's that's an important fight for us
for the people's party and i believe
that this country must be more open no
more lockdowns no more stay-at-home
orders no more curfew in montreal during
that uh
the at the peak of the kuvin 19 crisis
we had a curfew from eight o'clock p.m
to five o'clock a.m
and you know to fight a virus that's the
first time in the history of the world
that we do use lockdowns to fight a
virus that was an experiment a failed
experiment so my my vision for this
country i hope will be open i hope that
fear won't be them won't be there
anymore that people understand that we
can fight covet 19 with the vaccine and
there's other medication i'm not an
expert
medical expert but i know that there's
other medications we must promote other
medication
naturally or pharmaceutical one and and
we must reopen the economy no mass
mandate no lockdowns no vaccine passport
and we must go back to our life like it
was before
the that kuvid
started
okay so you're encouraging canadians in
some sense to take the risk to vote for
you and to vote for your new party
because you believe that that particular
side of the story let's say
seriously needs to be told and that it
needs to be told over and over and it
needs to be part of the national
discussion in parliament and all of that
so canadians who agree with
with the propositions that you just set
forward
if they vote for the ppc then they can
be reasonably assured that their voice
is at least going to be heard in the
national debate otherwise as far as
you're concerned the conservatives are
basically going to put together
something approximating a liberal
platform and all of this argument
libertarian argument in some sense for
increased freedom and for return to
essential normality and warning about
government overreach that's not going to
be part of the national conversation at
all
absolutely you're absolutely right about
that and i try to
to
i try for for that conversation to be
part of this elect of this election but
you know the mainstream media is
canceling us and just recently because
uh we are growing in the pool that they
are speaking about us but that growth
was ordinary canadian using their social
media speaking to their families their
friends about the bbc because our
biggest challenge right now is still a
lot of people don't know that we exist
don't know that there's another option
and we didn't have that conversation
during that electoral campaign all the
other political parties agree with the
vaccine passport and lockdowns and we
are the only one but we were not part of
that national debate in the mainstream
media and yes you're right
after this election we'll have a couple
of candidates that will be elected and i
i believe that i'll be able to be
re-elected in my riding in bose and
we'll have that conversation and the
mainstream media won't be able to ignore
us anymore
well you know one of the things that we
can talk about too is just exactly what
we're doing right now is that
increasingly as far as i can tell and i
believe this is going to be the wave of
the future and maybe this will transform
politics into in relatively radical ways
you can do what we're doing right now
and just talk directly to people you can
circumvent the media and that's going to
be more and more the case and so i'm
hoping that that will help us
well that'll produce a in some sense a
new breed of politician who speaks
directly to people and isn't trying to
craft their image so they look good when
presented in you know in the sound bites
that are characteristic of the legacy
media there's just no reason for that
anymore and so hopefully
we'll see people
present ideas that live or die on the
strength of the idea that would be
really nice so
yeah that would be
something and that's why we are using
social media a lot and i believe
the fact that we are very active on
social media and i want to thank you
also for giving me this opportunity to
speak to your viewers the fact that we
are more active on social media it is
helping us and yes there's a lack of
leadership in canadian politics
politicians are following the polls and
they try to tell you what you want to
hear and you know like in that political
campaign we have a huge deficit and they
want to spend more and more money yeah
okay so let's let's talk about that so
i'm going to play devil's advocate again
it's like well i thought about this and
i can understand the dangers of both the
debt and the deficit but but
the fact that these debts are being
racked up and the deficits as well seems
to be characteristic of western
democracies in general everyone seems to
be doing it and so it isn't obvious that
people will flee our currency because
we're in a relatively weak economic
position because of that because
everyone's doing it and so
um
why can't we just get away with this why
aren't we rich enough just to get away
with it what what do you think the
danger is and why do you think that your
analysis of that danger is credible
yeah because you know that
deficit and more and will have more
deficit because every
traditional establishment parties a
party are promoting more deficit more
spending with money that we don't have
but with borrowed money and and that
will that will increase our deficit and
update so why it's so important to
balance the budget because it's not our
children and grandchildren that will pay
for these deficits it is us right now it
is us right now and we are paying with
the inflation tax inflation is a hidden
tax instead of the government taking
your own money in your own pockets and
forcing you to give that to the
government the government is telling you
keep your money in your pocket but you
won't be able to buy the same amount
okay so let's let's walk through that so
i first of all i think it might be
useful just to distinguish for everyone
the difference between the deficit and
the debt yeah just so everyone knows the
terminology and then i would like you to
walk through why you think uh increased
government spending at the deficit and
debt level increases inflation and where
that's showing up in in canadians lives
okay first
the deficit is the deficit of last year
the deficit was 340
billion dollars and every day the
government is spending more money that
is collecting so every day that will add
that deficit is going to the debt and
every day we are adding to the debt so
when i'm speaking about balancing the
budget we are not speaking about paying
the debts no we are just picking at no
more deficit we don't want to increase
the debt anymore so that's that that's
very important but the other political
parties are ready to have more deficit
and that will put that will increase our
debt so right now like i said
we are paying because the inflation in
canada it's
4.4.1
that's the official
inflation in canada right now but if you
do your grocery you know that the
inflation the real inflation is bigger
bigger than that five six percent
inflation so that's why i said inflation
is a hidden tax because with the same
money that you have in your pocket you
cannot buy the same amount of goods and
services with that money your purchasing
power is going down your standard of
living is going down
our prices are going up and everybody is
poor so inflation is hidden tax and we
are paying right now
why don't you trust the official
inflation rate figures
why do you think it's higher than they
they state and where do you think that's
primarily showing up
because the way that they calculate the
inflation that's state canada and the
bank of canada it's a basket of goods
and services and in that basket they
don't put everything so yes we have a
four or five percent inflation in our
grocery but globally statistic canada is
telling off that it's 4.1
but 4.1
it is huge the bank of canada the bank
of canada has an inflation target of 2
now
it's more than 2 percent it's four point
one percent
but twenty percent inflation is no good
ten percent inflation is not good two
percent is not good we must have an
inflation target of zero percent and if
we have that the bank of canada won't be
able to print money out of thin air and
creating inflation because the inflation
is
is created by the bank of canada
and so our goal as a political party we
are the only political party that is
speaking about monetary policy that it's
important for the
the the the well-being of canadians
we want to have for the bank of canada a
zero inflation target we want people to
be able to keep that purchasing power so
that's so we could we could talk about
this in more straightforward terms too
so let's say there is a four
four to five percent
inflation rate for the next five to ten
years and what that means is that the
average canadian savings are going to be
cut in terms of their purchasing power
by
something exceeding 50 percent that
would be over a five to ten year period
so it doesn't sound like a lot for four
to five percent but it compounds across
time and it can add up to something
substantial in no time flat hey so i got
a question that's a little uh
pushing the envelope a little bit
um the cryptocurrency types you know the
people who are uh pushing bitcoin
bitcoin in particular
make the extraordinarily radical claim
that it would be better for everyone if
the entire business of money was taken
out of the hands of government
permanently and that's essentially what
bitcoin allows at least at the present
time and so that means that central
bankers and politicians would in
principle assuming this this is actually
a possibility would never be able to
print money and they would never be able
to inflate currency and
uh what do you think about those sorts
of cryptocurrency claims and and are
well i'd like to know what you think
about that i i agree with that i think
they're right we have a fiat currency
right now and and you know that's why
this inflation and we are losing our
possession power yes i believe i believe
that we must all have more competition
and the cryptocurrencies and the vidcon
can be an alternative but personally i
prefer a gold standard like we had in
the 19th century
here in canada because when you have a
gold standard the central bank won't be
able to print money out of thin air it's
another way to control the the the
central bank so and we had that before
in the past in the 19th century and
we
was very that was very uh prosperous a
time pressed per century so but but i'm
not against the cryptocurrency i think
we must have more competition you have
to the right on that
so so the the austrian economist the
hayek types and and they they believe
that the business cycle is actually the
boom and bust business cycle is actually
produced by
the attempts by government to overspend
in the face of so-called crises and that
produces inflation and all and a variety
of other factors that then
produce the business cycle in terms this
sequence of
essential busts and boobs and so does
that seem like a reasonable proposition
to you or do you look at it differently
than that no no i i think you're
absolutely right jordan uh you know
mrs rotbord that they're real economists
and and they know that and they're the
only ones that
wrote about that and studied that and i
believe yes the circle the circle that
we have the the up and downs in the
economy it's because of the central bank
you know money is everywhere and if you
create too too much money out of thin
air you'll have inflation and distortion
in the economy and boom and boost that
we have uh so so i 100 percent agree
with mrs rodbord hayek and uh and these
economists so you know i think these are
ideas just just
we'll move a bit sideways here again
i think a lot of what political leaders
could do if they had the intellectual
capacity
would be to use
forums like youtube to actually
educate the public and i don't mean
i don't mean i'm shaking my finger at
you because you need to be educated i
mean to walk people through the logic
and to explain why these propositions
are reasonable and to treat the public
as if they're capable of engaging in
actual intellectual exercise because my
experience on youtube has been that they
are
to a massively surprising degree because
i conduct these discussions with with
with
people i really admire and sometimes
those people are really really smart and
so the discussions go
fast and deep and
there's no evidence at all that people
aren't following along and there's
plenty of evidence that they really
appreciate it and so so
let's do this for a second so i would
like you to contrast your preparation to
be a leader of a political party and and
a figure of authority who dares to
discuss such issues economic issues
let's say with that of trudeau and
perhaps of o'toole like why are you the
guy and not trudeau and an auto tool
assuming well so let's go there
yeah
i'm doing just what you said you know
i'm using social media youtube i have a
youtube channel people's party of canada
and you know everything that i'm telling
you right now i said that in speeches 10
10 years ago on videos 10 years ago so
that's what i believe i'm in politics
because i believe in this idea these
ideas and i want them to be successful
so yes i believe i believe that
canadians are intelligence and i'm
saying always you know i don't try to
appeal as a to you as a canadian voter
to to your emotion i try to appeal to
your intelligence you know like
that discussion that we have uh you know
it's very difficult to have that
discussion uh in social media and all
that the the debates that they had in
canada and i was not part of that but
maybe i met very happy not that i was
not there because that was not a debate
that was somebody for the media without
any real discussion like we have right
now so yes i'm doing politics
differently and yes i believe that
people are intelligent and i don't want
to
i don't see people like children that we
must give them more security and more
regulations and a bigger government that
will control them
yeah well i also think it's it's
stunningly it's stunningly cynical on
the part of political leaders to manage
their their message
you know because it means that there's
no real faith in just direct discussion
and maybe and maybe no capacity for that
discussion to begin with i mean our
prime minister has stated publicly that
he's really not interested in monetary
policy and
what i read that i mean i read that two
ways is one well three ways one how
could you possibly
say that
and not notice what you just said and
second well perhaps that's because you
actually don't understand it and third
it's because not only do you not
understand it but you don't know how
terrible it is that you don't understand
it
absolutely absolutely and they don't
want to have
these kind of debates about real issues
uh and that's why our platform of the
last election is the same one we won't
change the issues because they're
popular or not and there's a lack of
leadership with politicians right now
because they all they they all do
politics by polling and survey and i
remember i have an example in canada
brian maroney maybe brian marley was not
so good but the election of 1988 the
election on the free trade agreement
with the u.s when brian monroe decided
to have that as a principal theme of his
campaign he said it's important to have
that freedom agreement for the
prosperity of our country when he
started that campaign in the polls
the majority 66 percent of the
population were against a free trade a
free create free trade sorry with the
u.s so the liberals the liberals and all
the other party was where on the side of
the majority of the population didn't
want to educate the population but
brownie brian only said it's important
for the future
all campaign on it
and my
and my goal is i will be able to
convince canadians on that and he was
able to do that at the end of the
campaign he had the biggest majority in
canadian history and that was a referred
on on the free trade agreement with the
u.s that's only an example with brian
maroney about that i'm not telling you
that he was the better the greatest
prime minister
that we had but that's an
example
sorry example of doing politics based on
principle and leadership but we don't
have that right now in canada a question
i discussed with rex murphy uh i talked
to rex earlier this week and posted his
analysis of the of the debate so let's
start a couple of things came out of
that that i thought were real
interesting the first is uh
the debate itself featured five main
topics and hypothetically those are the
most important issues facing canadians
so that was uh
let me see if i've got this right well
there was leadership and accountability
there was climate change there was
reconciliation there was affordability
uh into which everything to do with the
economy was lumped and then the last one
i believe was covid policy and when i
looked at that i thought well the choice
of the topics is actually the debate and
so what one of the things i really
wanted to ask you is okay
you're assessing something extraordinary
complex which is the state of the
country it's like okay what what are the
most important issues facing canadians
as far as you're concerned what do you
think we should be what do you think we
should be concentrating on
i think
we
we might just have a discussion about
yes kobe 19 and the impact of kobe 19
and all these uh
measures that these governments are
imposing to us that must be very
important second we must have a
discussion in canada about our
immigration policy
they are afraid to speak about that you
know that's important when you believe
in mass immigration
four hundred thousand people a year that
will come to our country after two years
it is the population of nova scotia a
new nova scotia every two years but the
worst of that it's the big majority of
them are refugees or people coming on
the reunification of family so i want to
have a discussion on immigration because
i love my country i want my country to
be like that in 25 years i don't want my
country to be like in france when
there's no go zone over there people
must come to our country and share our
values and they must know that men and
women are equal before the law we must
have a discussion about them and we must
welcome them but instead of having the
majority of our immigrants
refugees and re-education of family we
our immigration policy must be in line
with our economic needs and it is not
the case actually right now so that's
why we want fewer immigrants and more
more skilled immigrants economic
immigrant that will come here they will
have a job they will be able to
integrate our society
easily and so we don't have that
discussion it's always more and more and
if you have that discussion
people will look at you oh you're
xenophobe you may be racist no
actually we had that discussion in
quebec as you know i'm coming from
quebec that discussion about immigration
because for quebec their francophone
entity is very important and at the last
election lego that was elected and is
the premier of quebec now said during
the election he won 20
fewer immigrants nobody said that he was
a racist and he said these people must
come here and it would be better if they
can speak french if not we must be able
to give them a french lesson and so we
had a discussion at the provincial level
in quebec but in canada for the first
time at the last campaign we started
that discussion so i think it's
important for the future of this country
to have that discussion it's important
to have for the future of this country
to have the discussion on balancing the
budget like i said
we don't have this discussion and it's
sad
okay so you identified covid immigration
budget i mean the climate change issue
the tremendous amount of time was spent
on that and and that that drags up the
30 issue let's say of alberta and and
well in canada's canada is what
the the largest that that we've been
shown by divine providence so to speak
to give us these immense oil reserves
and so we have this industry and
and that's under assault in some sense
as a consequence of concern about
climate change and so albertans are
feeling the pressure of that sort of
discussion so
what what do you think about what do you
think about all that what's the way
forward
well we must smile you're absolutely
right jordan we must have a discussion
also on on
the paris accord and climate change we
have that discussion right now but it's
only on one side and we are the only
political party that is saying no to the
paris accord
we believe that there's no climate
emergency yes the climate is changing
and it will always change
and we
we believe that we can do better thing
better actions for the environment uh
and i said you know we won't impose a
carbon tax we won't sign the paris
accord what we will do we will be
we will do concrete actions for the
environment like uh you know we still
have lakes in our country that are not
clear and i'll i'll let the climate
change uh battle at the provincial level
because the beauty of that is the
environment is a shared jurisdiction in
canada with the federal and the
provincial government so let provincial
government deal with it and us at the
federal level will have other policies
but the one that we don't discuss also
is our equalization formula and i think
and i believe it is important for the
prosperity of our country but also for
the unity of our country when you have
jordan about 30 of the population in
alberta that want to separate because
they believe that the equalization
formula that is a formula that is
redistributing wealth in this country
from rich provinces to poor provinces
they think that it's unfair and i
believe that they have a right to say
that i think they think it's
particularly unfair when the
equalization payments are the way they
are and the province is simultaneously
demonized for the very economic uh
engine that allows those equalization
payments to be a reality
that's a bit much right to to have to
pay and then to be criticized for how
you raise the money so
yes yes
and that's another point that's why
they're not happy with that but
the traditional politicians the other
political parties don't want to speak
about that because they need to have a
solution and the solution and they don't
want to speak about the solution because
you have to educate the population the
solution is what to be less generous we
need to do a distribution it is in the
constitution we need to have a formula
but the federal government is in charge
of that formula and the federal
government can decide
how much money it will give to other
provinces to have not provinces and we
can be less generous because now
there's no incentive for quebec or new
brunswick to develop their own natural
resources there's a lot of shell gas in
quebec and newborns if they do that they
would be more prosperous and they
receive fewer money from the
equalization formula i was in new
brunswick and i'll give you an anecdote
at the last campaign and
i did a rally over there and i spoke
about the equalization formula i said we
must cut it we must must be less
generous to give the right incentive to
your parents to be
to exploit extract their own natural
resources and that formula is unfair
and a journalist from cbc
was there that
at that rally and they they asked me
after that mr bernie i want you
with me live tomorrow morning
at seven o'clock
i said i'll be there
and when i was there the discussion she
said would be only on the equalization
from milan you have three minutes i said
okay she start you you want to cut the
equalization formula i said not cutting
all the formula but i want to be less
generous do you know mr bernie that here
in newborns week half of our budget is
coming from the equalization formula i
said yes i know that half of the
provincial budget i know that so mr
bernie i don't understand you you want
to have support here in new new
brunswick you want people to vote for
you and you are telling them that you
will cut half of their provincial budget
i said yes i said yes i will do that but
on a transition period because i believe
in your people you're not a poor
province here you're a rich province you
have bad economic policy at the
financial level and we need to give the
right incentive to your province to have
more free markets develop develop more
your natural resources that you have but
we'll do that on a transition period and
that will be fair for everybody and
every province so you need to have the
courage of your conviction and having
discussion like that but the other
political parties don't want to speak
about that because they will have to
speak like that in new brunswick and in
quebec and they're pandering to these
provinces for votes so and it's
important for me because in a country
canada and in western canada they know
that that formula is not fair and i'm
saying the same thing in french in
quebec and in atlantic canada and all
across the country and that's why i
believe we have a lot of support in
western canada because they know that we
have the solution they are not happy
with ottawa right now and they have
great reason for not being happy
so you talked about small government you
talked about balancing the budget
and
so let's talk about concrete issues
there so
where is the government federally being
particularly profligate and what would
you do or what do you think should be
done how do you analyze the problem and
what do you think
would go a long ways to solving it
yeah so so what i think i i i believe
that we must respect the constitution
it's all about our constitution we have
a good constitution a great constitution
the problem is politicians don't respect
our constitution if you do that you will
have a radical decentralization in
canada you will give more autonomy to
alberta and every provinces and you know
if in alberta they want to have their
police force like in quebec they will be
able to have that if in alberta they
want to have more private delivery for
health cares
healthcare services they would be able
to have that if they want to have their
own pension plan they would be able to
have that so let's have a radical
decentralization and like that you won't
have any constitutional crisis and you
have more prosperity so that's our
vision of our country that is based on
on the division that the father of our
constitution uh had in
okay so so you see decentralization as a
way of promoting
economic experimentation at least in
part but you also think that it would
take some of the pressure off
regional concerns
and what about what about federal
spending per se i mean what is it that
the government's spending
poorly
where is government spending being
conducted particularly poorly and what
do you think should be done about that
and what kind of what kind of numbers
are we looking at
yeah absolutely so you're right about
giving more autonomy to provinces and i
want them to be able to raise their
money for their own responsibility so
but the the federal government has a
role and the role of the federal
government is
to be sure that you know we'll be able
to invest in our canadian forces we are
in charge of the monetary policy we need
to have a real economic union in this
country that we don't have and and to be
able to do all that we need to cut
spending uh you know i believe that we
must not give subsidies to businesses we
must have a policy that would be fair
every business must have a flat tax of
so i don't believe it's fair to tax a
small business in toronto and forcing
these entrepreneurs to pay taxes and
after that we are giving that to gm or
bombardier let's have let's abolish that
we can save about eight to ten billion
dollars so we want to have a smaller
government that will spend in their
jurisdiction and and let provinces
deal with their own responsibility you
know we are transferring in canada 41
billion dollars to provinces for
healthcare
i don't want to do that healthcare is a
100 provincial jurisdiction we must be
sure that ontario and every province
will be able to raise money for their
own responsibility and we know that the
best government
is the government that is near the
people so to do that instead of the
federal government taxing people and
after that giving that to provinces and
sometime with conditions we must abolish
that and we must give them the gst
actually we are raising in canada 41
billion dollars with the gst
we must do a tax point transfer the gst
will be managed by provinces and they
will be able to raise money for the
healthcare and they will be independent
they won't be able to come to ottawa for
us
asking for more money all the time so
they will be in a position for
healthcare for example
to find the best system for their
citizen is it more money in a socialist
system or maybe more competition
and and and canadians will know who to
blame for a lack of services in
healthcare and for waiting uh list
now they don't know who to blame is it
the federal government because the
federal government is not giving enough
money to provinces or is it the province
because they're not able to manage
efficiently their health care system so
the pressure will be on the provinces
and they will have all the tools and the
responsibility to deal with it and maybe
we'll have competition maybe in quebec
you'll have more private delivery maybe
in altar you'll have less and the best
system will
the best system will come and like in
other countries when you have an
universal coverage but people can choose
to go to a private delivery a private
clinic or a
public hospital we don't have the best
system for that but it's under the
provincial jurisdiction i cannot change
the system but i can give the incentive
for them to change it by giving them the
the the gst they will raise that tax and
they will keep that tax and all the
incomes coming from the gst and they
will be responsible
so let's turn to just briefly if if you
don't mind we'll turn to another topic
of the debate so a fifth of the debate
was about reconciliation and canada's
flags have been flying at half-mast for
six months or something like that and
um
my sense of that part of the debate was
that none of the real issues were ever
discussed um and so this is
i think of reserves
in some sense the canadian reserves are
the vast majority of them as akin in
to the small towns in canada that have
been absolutely devastated over the last
40 years they're without economic
viability you see them drying up all
over saskatchewan and alberta these and
out in atlanta canada as well because
these little outposts just can't survive
they don't have the economy for it
anymore and i
so and i didn't see anybody talk about
that particular problem which seems to
be the big one um
so i think that these attempts at
reconciliation are going to be lumped in
with the big lies in no time flat
because we're not addressing the real
issues uh maybe i'm wrong am i wrong
what do you think about that issue and
and
is it something that the ppc is
concentrating on is it something that's
that's that's
of the nature of a crisis
what should be done yeah
you're not wrong you're not wrong jordan
the solution is there the solution is
there and we have we have a policy a
platform for the first nation and i was
in invention and unveiled that platform
with uh some of our candidates that one
of them is an atheist and others or a
first nation
and they agree with our platform what we
need to do we need to turn the page and
build a new relationship with the first
nation based on property rights on
reserve base not on a top-down approach
that what is that is what is happening
right now you know we don't have clean
water on reserve and
ottawa cannot solve that they must be
able to solve okay so why why why
specify property rights what do you see
that be what why is that the issue
because you know you cannot
if if you're on reserve you cannot uh
you can have a house but you can have
you cannot have a mortgage you don't
have any property it's a kind of a
communist system on reserve there's no
property right there there's some
reserve in dc that they've developed a
kind of a property right when you don't
have any property rights on reserve
people living on reserve
they are dependent they cannot build
wealth they cannot have a house they
cannot have a board okay so canadians
don't canadians don't understand this i
don't understand this so what's the
typical economic arrangement so i'm a
i'm a first nations person i'm living on
a reservation i have a house but i don't
have a house according to you i don't
have property rights who owns the land
who has the rights to it
how does that work exactly and why is it
a problem
yeah that that that's the reserve you
have a house yes but you you cannot do
what you want in that house because
that's that's under the
the authority of the of the reserve uh
and that's why you know you don't have
people and you have the indian account
so that is managing everything and the
indian act it's a racist act it is based
on race so we need to abolish that but
the problem is if you want to abolish it
the other question is you will replace
that by what and we don't have the
solution but when i'm saying that to
people
to to first nation they agree that we
must abolish gender act but they want to
be part of the solution what i'm telling
them yes we want you to be fully
participating in our society being part
of the solution let's abolish that and
after that having a discussion for a
better future on reserve a kind of a
property rights on reserve well it must
be very it must be very hard for people
to be incentivized to improve their
property to invest in their property etc
if they have no stake in the future of
that property or if that's distributed
entirely in ways that are beyond their
personal control
yeah but i i don't
i want people to understand that they
have a house they can do what they want
in their house but they cannot mortgage
that right
so they can they can improve it
and that's why but
that's the discussion that we must have
with them but we don't have a discussion
we don't want to have that discussion
because the solution is complicated and
oh and we prefer to give money to them
billions of dollars
but that they don't want them they want
more autonomy they want to be able you
know to to have maybe the same
responsibility like like a municipality
so let's have a discussion we need to
respect treaties yes we can do that but
we need to open that and and but the
mainstream
political parties are not ready for that
because they don't have the solution why
do the metis
people who are running for your party
agree with that what what what do they
see that's valuable for them
because they see that we are able to
speak about that they know that we don't
have all the solution but they know that
the principle where we went base our
relationship nation to nation respecting
everybody turning the page about the
past not ottawa will be there i'm
telling you what to do every time so
abolishing the indian act they they like
all that but they want to participate
with us to find the solution
and they want to have that discussion
that's why they agree with our position
so i would like you to tell me your
opinion about
what's happened in canada at the federal
level under trudeau so what's your story
of trudeau's government
what how should we conceptualize it and
and what do you think about it and why
i believe it's a failure uh first of all
trudeau said in the beginning of his
mandate the first one that canada is the
first post
post-national nation country with no
core identity
and
and i think that that was his goal and
now with the racial politic that we have
in this country and trudeau was
successful to put us in a little box you
know you are black
we have a policy for you
like he did you know
a new program for black entrepreneurs
only for black entrepreneurs that's
racial politics that's trudeau
for me is the most divisive prime
minister in our history we need to
abolish programs like that we need if
you want to have a program for
entrepreneurs we need to have a program
for all entrepreneurs and not only for
black entrepreneurs so
and that's why we that i believe that's
why people are are
our people are ready to have that
discussion and more and more people the
world culture put out you know when
trudeau said
there's no recession anymore the sea
session
and you know what what's that oh because
he believed that a recession would be
harder on women so it's all that
political correctness at the extreme and
i said no to political correctness long
time ago there's no taboo subject for us
and trudeau
you know all that wall culture and you
know that better than mid jordan it was
all in the university universities
couple of years ago and now it's it's in
the civil society with
and that that's the trudeau heritage and
also the big deficit and
and the inflation
and so what do you
what do you think of trudeau personally
how how do you assess him his character
and his fitness for leadership and
and maybe you could also say the same
about o'toole and would you rather see
o'toole or or trudeau as prime minister
well you know we will have all tool to
do in a couple of days but
both of them both of them i don't like
because
i don't like them because they don't
have any character
they're following the polls and you know
some someday they're saying something
the the other day they're saying the
opposite uh but trudeau i can tell you
that he's a good communicator uh you
know he's able to have one line and with
the mainstream media everything you know
it was a a
teacher
teacher so i understand that he's very
good uh but
there's there's nothing he is uh for me
is a
a puppet and he will say what uh
what do you think
a puppet of of
the uh the establishment of the liberal
party of canada and the establishment
they want they want to stay in power and
they will do everything to stay in power
they will be trudeau said couple of
months ago that imposing a vaccine
passport will be too divisive that's why
i won't do that and now he's seeing the
opposite why because you look at the
polls and he knows that more people are
ready for that so there's no leadership
there you know he is
he is uh he's listening his advisor and
he will say everything to be elected and
utool is the same so i
i don't have any
uh i i i don't know trudeau personally i
don't know o'toole personally i know
them like every canadian and i'm judging
them by their policies as political
leaders and for me
the policies that they promote
is not the right policies for our
country and for the future of our
country
another question when when you think
about canada the way it is now like uh
murphy told me for example that that he
conceptualizes canada he sees well we
we're we we're regional country there's
the atlantic provinces there's ontario
there's quebec there's the western
provinces bc is its own place there's
the north so when you envision canada um
what
where do you see its regional divisions
and and what does the ppc have to offer
let's say each of those particular
regions
yeah first
i agree with that we have different
regions in this country that but the
most important for me we have different
culture the culture of quebec is
different of the culture of alberta but
that's our country and and we cannot
change that but we are united we are
united because we share the same values
and if we want to have a conscious
constitutional peace in our country we
need to have more decentralization every
province's province or we must be able
to do what they want to do if something
is very important in alberta and they
want to have i don't know
their own case that they pull their own
pension plan they must be able to have
that so that's why i you know what we
are doing it's not we don't try to
reopen our constitution or to rewrite
our constitution we just want the
federal government to respect the
constitution and by doing that that will
give more autonomy to provinces and you
will have the constitutional peace in
this country and yes it's beautiful that
we have different culture in this
country and we are unique in the world
with that so we are canadian and that's
part of our identity as canadian so what
do you think it is that unites us across
those regions as far as you're concerned
what it what is it this so trudeau said
while we're the first post nation nation
in some sense we don't have a central
culture um
you don't agree with that obviously what
do you think it is that unites us across
those fairly
uh pervasive regional differences
it's our history or our culture that is
different in different regions uh is
our charter of rights uh our freedom the
the fact that we want every canadian to
be every canadian to be called before
the law uh our western civilization
values
and the fact that yes uh you know in
quebec you can speak french over there
and we don't impose that to anybody and
in alberta you know that's an anglophone
province and outside but people
appreciate that and yet but they don't
want anything being imposed by the
federal government so let provinces do
what they want to do but our country is
not the country that justin trudeau
wants to build a country more divisive
and and you know for him you are not
canadian if you are
if you are
a canadian from from china uh he will he
will and o'tool will do the same thing
he will call you a chinese canadian or a
pakistanis canadians no
people came here to celebrate our
freedoms and everybody
for me is a canadian i don't care you
know if i'm speaking with a person uh
the different ethnicity that you are a
chinese canadian no you are a canadian
and these people came in here to
celebrate and to become canadians so
that divisive politics that identity
politics is is killing killing our our
country and we want to stop that and and
having policies that will look at
everybody
as a canadian and not try to to do that
pandering to to a region or pandering to
an ethnicity like the traditional
politicians are doing right now
so if canadians vote for you on monday
elections on monday
um
what's their reward for doing that we
can return to that to some degree
yeah
like i said i want them not to vote
against something i want them to vote
for something for their values for what
they believe and look if you like our
platform i hope you support us what will
be after the election i can tell you
that i won't be the leader of the
opposition i won't be prime minister but
you will have a freedom voice netawa you
will have a common sense voice in ottawa
you will have a voice that is ready to
do these important debates for the
future of our country that's what i can
tell you and we will start that common
sense revolution together that's only
the beginning of uh
another step for the people's party of
canada at the beginning of that common
sense revolution in this country
well we've gone 90 minutes that is a
nice closing statement i guess i'm
wondering if there's anything else you'd
like to discuss or add
and apart from that then i think that
that's a nice wrap
no i appreciate that yeah i appreciate
that mr peterson jordan i'm very pleased
that you gave me that opportunity to to
be out there and to reach more people
that's the most important for us that's
our biggest challenge so yes we can end
there and yeah it'll be interesting yeah
interesting to see how people respond to
this because
well because i'm hoping that this kind
of discussion can become a model for a
different kind of political dialogue in
the future and one that's not mediated
so much by media handlers and appearance
and all of that but that's predicated on
straight
blunt
somewhat complicated talk and and and i
guess we'll see how that works we'll
launch this as soon as we possibly can
[Music]
you